in a basketball world looking for the  latest superhero one vigilante wants to  change the game  mohamad Bamba is not your average high  school pupil  what's in your bag mo nothing  but his classmates have no idea that he  is wingspan the six foot 11 inch  superhero that has saved their  basketball season hey mo are you burning  a game after this yeah why haven't you  been to a basketball game yet this  season my gosh I'm just not that  interested in basketball  when wingspan takes the basketball court  he puts on a show and as part of the  effort to make the big man not just the  focal point again but make them  unstoppable  92 inches across hand to hand  creating matchup problems for everyone  he faces his mission remains guarding  his City and his high school from all  basketball Ryan's wingspan possibly  coming to your favorite college program  in the fall of 2017